ABOUT THIS THAN THE HEATED
GUBERNATORIAL RACE IN GEORGIA.
>> Reporter: IN AN ELECTION
YEAR, EVEN YOUR LOCAL FARMERS
MARKET COULD BECOME THE SITE OF
A SURPRISE CAMPAIGN STOP.
>> STACY, WE'RE BIG FANS.
>> Reporter: HERE IN GEORGIA,
THE FUTURE OF ABORTION RIGHTS
HAS BECOME CENTRAL TO DEMOCRATIC
NOMINEE FOR GOVERNOR STACEY
ABRAMS' STRATEGY TO WIN IN
NOVEMBER.
>> HOW MUCH OF AN EMPHASIS DO
YOU PLAN ON PUTTING ON ABORTION
RIGHTS IN THE CLOSING WEEKS OF
YOUR CAMPAIGN?
>> IT IS GOING TO BE FRONT AND
CENTER IN THE CONVERSATION.
WOMEN DESERVE FULL CITIZENSHIP
IN THE UNITED STATES AN
CERTAINLY IN THE STATE OF
GEORGIA AND THEY ARE BEING
DENIED THAT BECAUSE OF BRIAN
KEMP'S DRACONIAN SIX-WEEK BAN.
>> Reporter: IN 2019 BRIAN KEMP
SIGNED A BILL INTO LAW THAT BANS
MOST ABORTIONS WHEN EARLY
CARDIAC ACTIVITY IS DETECTED,
USUALLY AT AROUND SIX WEEKS OF
PREGNANCY.
THE LAW WAS BLOCKED UNTIL ROE
WAS OVERTURNED.
EMPHASIZING ABORTION RIGHTS HAS
PROVED TO BE SUCCESSFUL RECENTLY
FOR DEMOCRATIC HOUSE CANDIDATES
IN REPUBLICAN-LEANING ALASKA AND
A BATTLEGROUND NEW YORK DISTRICT
SIGNALING THE ISSUE HAS LIKELY
ENERGIZED DEMOCRATIC VOTERS.
IN THE WAKE OF THE SUPREME
COURT'S DECISION.
>> I DEFINITELY THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING PEOPLE SHOULD CONSIDER
WHILE THEY'RE VOTING.
>> I THINK IT COULD BE THE
DIFFERENCE IN OUR STATE.
>> Reporter: A RECENT QUINNIPIAC
BOWL ABOUT THE MIDTERMS IN
GEORGIA SHOWED 57% OF LIKELY
VOTERS SAY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT A
CANDIDATE SHARES THEIR VIEWS ON
ABORTION.
WITHIN THAT GROUP, 63% BACK
ABRAMS, AND 36% SUPPORT KEMP.
>> WE CAN DO THIS WORK.
>> Reporter: THE DAUGHTER OF
METHODIST PASTORS, ABRAMS WAS
NOT ALWAYS A FIERCE ADVOCATE FOR
ABORTION RIGHTS.
ON THE TRAIL, SHE TALKS ABOUT
HER PERSONAL EVOLUTION ON
ABORTION, AMPLIFYING THE ISSUE
LAST MONTH AT A ROUNDTABLE FOR
WOMEN WHO HAVE SUFFERED
PREGNANCY LOSS.
>> WHAT GIVES ME THE GREATEST
HOPE IS THAT YOU ALL ARE
SPEAKING OF.
>> Reporter: MEANWHILE GOVERNOR
KEMP IS PRINCIPALLY FOCUSED ON
ECONOMIC ISSUES, SUCH AS
INFLATION, WHICH LIKELY GEORGIA
VOTERS RANK AS THE MOST URGENT
ISSUE.
IN A STATEMENT TO CNN, HIS
CAMPAIGN SAYS THE GOVERNOR HAS
CONSISTENTLY FOCUSED ON HIS
POSITION ON ABORTION AND WILL
FOCUS ON RELIEF FROM 40-YEAR
HIGH INFLATION.
>> PEOPLE WANTING TO MAKE IT
JUST ABOUT ONE ISSUE, BUT I
THINK PEOPLE NEED TO BE
CONCERNED ABOUT PAYING FOR THEIR
GROCERIES AND FOR GASOLINE TOO.
>> WE ALSO PROTECTED THE
SANCTITY OF GOD'S GREATEST GIFT,
LIFE.
>> Reporter: SPEAKING BEFORE A
CONSERVATIVE ANTI-ABORTION
POLICY GROUP THIS MONTH, KEMP
SPENT LITTLE TIME TALKING ABOUT
ABORTION.
>> YOU KNOW, WE PASSED THE
HEARTBEAT BILL HERE, BUT WE'VE
ALSO DONE ADOPTION REFORM.
WE HAVE DONE -- WE HAVE DONE
FOSTER CARE REFORM.
>> Reporter: HISTORICALLY KEMP
HAS SUPPORTED A FULL BAN, WITH
THE ONLY EXCEPTION BEING FOR THE
LIFE OF PREGNANT PERSON.
BUT PRAISED THE SUPREME COURT
RETURNING THE ISSUE TO THE
STATES.
WHILE ABRAMS DOESN'T SUPPORT ANY
RESTRICTIONS ON ABORTION,
CLAIMING THAT IT'S A MEDICAL
ISSUE.
KEMP HAS ADOPTED A LESS STRIDENT
TONES ATHE CONVERSATION ABOUT
REPRODUCTIVE CARE HAS BECOME SO
PIVOTAL IN THE CLOSING MONTHS OF
THE CAMPAIGN.
>> I UNDERSTAND PEOPLE MAY
DISAGREE ON WHEN AN ABORTION
SHOULD BE LEGAL OR WHEN IT
SHOULDN'T BE.
>> Reporter: NOW, TO BE CLEAR,
AS ABRAMS CRISSCROSSED THE STATE
THIS WEEKEND, SHE TALKED ABOUT
OTHER ISSUES AS WELL, LIKE
MEDICAID EXPANSION, LIKE THE
NEED TO REINSTITUTE FREE
TECHNICAL COLLEGE AND ADDRESSED
THE GROWING NUMBER OF HOSPITAL
CLOSURES IN THIS STATE.
STILL SHE ARGUES THAT ABORTION
IS NOT ONLY AN ECONOMIC ISSUE,
IT IS ONE ABOUT CIVIL LIBERTIES
AS WELL, AND SHE CONTINUES TO
PUT IT FRONT AND CENTER.
JAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, EVA, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
LET'S DISCUSS WITH OUR PANEL.
KASIE, LET ME START WITH YOU AND
GET REACTION TO EVA'S GREAT
REPORTING FROM GEORGIA.
I CAN UNDERSTAND WHY THAT
SPECIAL HOUSE ELECTION IN NEW
YORK COULD BE DRIVEN BY THE
DEMOCRAT PUSHING ABORTION
RIGHTS.
IS IT A RISK IN PLACES LIKE
GEORGIA, THOUGH?
>> IT COULD BE.
I THINK IN THE CASE OF STACEY
ABRAMS, LOOK AT THE CAMPAIGN
SHE'S RUN IN THE PAST AND HOW
SHE RUNS THEM.
SHE RUNS TURNOUT ELECTIONS AND
THIS IS A TURNOUT ISSUE.
WE'VE SEEN MORE DEMOCRATS,
ESPECIALLY WOMEN, GET OUT TO
REGISTER TO VOTE AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THEY ARE ACTIVATED ON.
SHE'S DONE WITH IT BLACK VOTERS
IN THE PAST ON VOTING RIGHTS AND
THAT SORT OF RINGS A LITTLE TRUE
TO ME.
I ALSO THINK I'D BE REALLY
INTERESTED TO SEE DEEP POLLING
NUMBERS ON THE ATLANTA SUBURBS
TO SEE HOW THIS PLAYS WITH WHITE
WOMEN VOTERS WHO WERE WILLING TO
VOTE FOR RAPHAEL WARNOCK OVER
DAVID PERDUE BACK IN THE SENATE
RACES THAT FLIPPED THOSE TWO
SEATS OVER TO DEMOCRATS.
>> YEAH, AND I WONDER IF THE
SIX-WEEK BAN, I WONDER IF IN HIS
HEART OF HEARTS, IF GOVERNOR
KEMP WOULD DO IT DIFFERENTLY
TODAY AND MAKE IT A 15-WEEK BAN
OR SOMETHING MORE PALATABLE TO
VOTERS.
>> PROBABLY, RIGHT, BECAUSE
HINDSIGHT IS 20/20.
WHO KNEW THIS WOULD BE SUCH AN
ISSUE IN THIS ELECTION, RIGHT?
I THINK THE THINKING WAS ONCE IT
WAS LEAKED, THE MOMENTUM THE
DEMOCRATS INITIALLY HAD FROM THE
RULING WAS THAT IT MAY HAVE BEEN
DISSIPATED BY NOW, RIGHT?
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN IS THAT, NO,
DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
MOMENTUM.
SO I THINK IN HINDSIGHT, A, THIS
IS SOMETHING GOVERNOR KEMP
DOESN'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
B, IF HE HAD TO DO IT OVER
AGAIN, HE WOULD DO IT AFTER THE
ELECTION.
>> AND I THINK YOUR POINT IS THE
RIGHT ONE, JAKE.
SIX WEEKS, EXCEPTION ONLY FOR
LIFE OF THE MOTHER.
NO EXCEPTION FOR RAPE OR INCEST.
THAT'S REALLY NOT WHERE MOST
AMERICANS ARE AS GEORGIA IS
INCREASINGLY A STATE IN THE
MIDDLE.
>> YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BEFORE, SCOTT.
IT USED TO BE EASY FOR
REPUBLICANS TO PAINTING
DEMOCRATS AS EXTREMISTS BUT NOW
THE ISSUE PLAYS THE COMPLETE
OTHER WAY.
>> IT DEPENDS ON WHO YOU ARE AND
WHERE YOU ARE.
I THINK GEORGIA'S BILL OBVIOUSLY
GOES A LITTLE FURTHER THAN WHAT
LINDSEY GRAHAM HAS BEEN OUT
TALKING ABOUT.
THE QUESTION ABOUT WHERE ARE
MOST AMERICANS.
I THINK THEY'RE WHERE LINDSEY
GRAHAM IS, 15 WEEKS, THE THREE
EXCEPTIONS.
AND SO I THINK KEMP -- IT'S NO
SECRET THAT BRIAN KEMP IS A PRO
LIFE CANDIDATE.
I MEAN HE RAN AS A PRO LIFER.
I DON'T THINK HE REALLY SHIES
AWAY FROM IT.
I DO THINK THE REPORTING THERE
IS INTERESTING, THOUGH.
THE PARTIES ARE HAVING TWO
DIFFERENT CONVERSATIONS WITH TWO
DIFFERENT GROUPS OF VOTERS.
REPUBLICANS ARE HAVING AN
ECONOMY, INFLATION, IMMIGRATION,
BORDER CRIME AND DEMOCRATS ARE
HAVING TRUMP, ABORTION, CLIMATE
CHANGE, GUN VIOLENCE.
IT'S REALLY FASCINATING WHEN YOU
SEE ONE ELECTION BUT TWO
DISTINCT CONVERSATIONS --
>> IT'S A FIGHT OVER --
>> IT'S REALLY INTERESTING.
>> I THINK ONE OF THE REASONS
WHY REPUBLICANS WANT TO HAVE A
DIFFERENT CONVERSATION IS
BECAUSE I DO THINK THEY ARE
AFRAID ABOUT HOW VISCERAL THIS
HAS BECOME, HOW EFFECTIVE THIS
HAS BECOME FOR WOMEN.
AND BY THE WAY, WOMEN KNEW THIS
WAS GOING TO BE AS EFFECTIVE AS
IT IS, RIGHT WHEN THIS WAS
LEAKED AND ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
SUPREME COURT DID OVERTURN IT,
BECAUSE THIS IS ABOUT WOMEN'S
CHOICE.
THIS IS ABOUT GIVING WOMEN THE
SAME RIGHTS THAT ALL MEN HAVE TO
MAKE DECISIONS OVER THEIR OWN
BODIES.
AND I THINK WHAT REPUBLICANS
DIDN'T REALLY UNDERSTAND WAS HOW
MUCH IT WAS GOING TO MOBILIZE
AND ENERGIZE NOT JUST DEMOCRATIC
WOMEN, BUT DEMOCRATIC MEN,
INDEPENDENT MEN, INDEPENDENT
WOMEN, FAMILIES WHO UNDERSTAND
THAT THIS DECISION SHOULD BE IN
NO ONE'S HANDS EXCEPT FOR THE
WOMEN.
AND BY THE WAY, THIS ISN'T JUST
WHITE SUBURBAN WOMEN, BLACK
WOMEN, LATINO WOMEN.
THIS IS A POLL OF LATINO VOTERS,
ABORTION WAS THE NUMBER TWO
ISSUE AMONG LATINO VOTERS.
IT'S ASTOUNDING HOW MUCH THIS
HAS RESONATED.
>> WERE THEY IN FAVOR OF
ABORTION RIGHTS?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
>> BECAUSE A LOT OF LATINOS ARE
CATHOLIC.
>> RIGHT.
BUT THIS IS THE ANOMALY.
PRIVACY, LIBERTY AND FREEDOM,
HUGE ISSUES AMONG THE LATINO
COMMUNITY.
>> SO ANOTHER BIG RACE IN
GEORGIA BETWEEN THE INCOME BENT
SENATOR REVEREND RAPHAEL WARNOCK
AND FORMER FOOTBALL STAR
HERSCHEL WALKER.
THEY HAVE A DEBATE COMING UP.
HERSCHEL WALKER WAS ASKED HOW HE
WAS PREPARING HIMSELF FOR THIS
DEBATE.
HE DIDN'T EXACTLY SET THE BAR
HIGH.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> TALKING TO THE VOTERS.
TALKING TO YOU.
YOU TOLD ME I'VE GOT TO PREPARE,
SO I'M PREPARING.
I'M JUST A COUNTRY BOY.
I'M NOT THAT SMART AND HE'S THAT
PREACHER.
HE'S A SMART MAN, WEARS THESE
NICE SUITS.
SO HE'S GOING TO SHOW UP AND
EMBARRASS ME AT THE DEBATE.
I'M GOING TO SHOW UP AND DO MY
BEST.
>> I'VE NEVER HEARD A CANDIDATE
FOR OFFICE DESCRIBE HIMSELF AS
NOT THAT SMART.
>> WELL, IF YOU LIKEN THIS TO A
BOXING MATCH, RIGHT, HE'S UP
AGAINST SOMEONE WHO IN MARTIN
LUTHER KING'S POOL.
SO YOU WANT TO NEUTRALIZE HIS
STRONGEST PUNCH, A.
B, YOU WANT TO JUST -- YOU WANT
THE JUDGES TO SAY, OKAY, IF HE
DOES LAND A PUNCH, OH, WE SAW
THAT COMING, THAT'S NO BIG DEAL.
AND C, IF YOU'RE HERSCHEL
WALKER, IF YOU'RE ABLE TO LAND A
JAB OR TWO ON THAT DEBATE NIGHT,
YOU WANT THE JUDGES TO COME
AWAY, HEY, HE WENT TOE TO TOE.
>> THIS IS CAMPAIGN 101.
LOWERING EXPECTATIONS AHEAD OF A
DEBATE AND TO YOUR POINT MAKING
IT SEEM LIKE ANY GOOD THING YOU
DO -- ANY -- WE MIGHT AGREE ON
THIS TODAY.
THIS IS CAMPAIGN 101.
>> BUT TO DESCRIBE YOURSELF AS
NOT SMART?
>> JAKE, I'M SORRY, BUT THAT
SHIP HAS SAILED IN OUR POLITICS.
IF ANYTHING, YOU KNOW, PEOPLE
ARE MORE INTERESTED IN
CANDIDATES WHO ARE ANTI-ELITIST.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
>> THAN THOSE WHO TOUT THEIR
CREDENTIALS.
>> SOMETIMES BEING SMART IS NOT
THE GREATEST THING, JAKE, NOT
AROUND THIS TABLE.
BUT I THINK IN GENERAL PEOPLE --
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY ESPECIALLY
HAS MADE BEING SMART, BEING
KNOWLEDGEABLE, FOCUSING YOUR
ARGUMENTS ON FACTS AND EVIDENCE
NOT A GOOD THING.
IT CAN BE A DOWNSIDE.
AND FOR HERSCHEL WALKER, WHO IS
A HUGE HERO, RIGHT, AMONG THE
GEORGIA ELECTORATE, ESPECIALLY
THE MAGA ELECTORATE, I DON'T
THINK HE CAN GO WRONG WITH THAT.
AND SO I THINK THE WARNOCK
CAMPAIGN IS NOT DISSING THAT
BECAUSE I THINK THEY SEE THAT IS
GOING TO BE, NO MATTER WHAT YOU
THINK OF HERSCHEL WALKER, IT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY DIFFICULT
RACE FOR HIM.
>> GEORGIA IN GENERAL, BY THE
WAY, REPUBLICANS ARE FEELING
INCREASINGLY GOOD ABOUT THIS
STATE.
EVERYONE THINKS BRIAN KEMP IS
BEATING STACEY ABRAMS RIGHT NOW.
INCREASING GOOD FEELINGS ABOUT
WALKER'S POSITION.
CLOSE RACE.
KIND OF A PURPLISH STATE.
BUT PEOPLE ARE FEELING SOME
MO